folks once again donald trump and his
supporters have done exactly
what they said they were going to do
[Music]
so for those of you who have maybe been
living under a rock or something like
that donald trump has been contesting
the election
for months now basically spinning
conspiracy theories about what happened
lying about fraudulent ballot et cetera
et cetera i think that from the
beginning trump
never really thought he could could win
after election night he
believed it wasn't gonna work but doing
everything he could
to so doubt everything he could to
maintain his ego
because that's what it comes down to and
i've seen people like this
you know this is somebody who's a basic
narcissist i think
who is looking at it only from well
what's gonna happen to me how does this
affect my
[ __ ] appearance to others this lie is
such a dangerous one because it's a
pretty huge [ __ ] lie he's setting the
stage
for a new terrifying era in
in american history i think i've seen
some people talking about this
attempted coup as the death throes
of the trump presidency as the dying
gasps of
a failed american presidency no he this
is
it's been four [ __ ] years of
normalizing
trump has let the the [ __ ] worst
element of this country have free reign
i am
extremely privileged because i don't see
the worst of it i can only hear and
listen to others who are
directly affected by the the actions of
the trump administration trump has given
legitimacy to
white nationalists nazis and it's
spreading over the world i mean let's be
real i mean the united states is
exporting this [ __ ] around the world
and the inevitability of this
attempted coup you know it shouldn't be
surprising anybody how could trump
inspire a mob to go break into the
capitol building
honestly if you think these things
you've been living in a in an insanely
tight
small bubble if you haven't watched any
kind of conservative media if you
haven't listened to or talked to any
conservatives
i'm not talking about whatever
republicans they have on cnn who talking
about how old
we condemn trump and the way he acts
those people are extremely rare they
don't exist except in the media because
that's a
narrative for some [ __ ] reason the
media wants to promote and wants to push
these people and the truth is that
the people who stormed the capital are
regular
[ __ ] trump republicans they are
people are talking about how they're far
right radical most of them people who
were there who were
climbing into the capitol building
they're just like every other
trump supporting republican and to them
to trump's base
which is basically the whole republican
party which is basically half of this
country
this was an amazing moment and that's
what makes me
so so pissed and sad about about this
because
this is a historical moment okay you
know a mob
coming into the capitol building i mean
this is totally historic
and you have these images of confederate
flag waving
in the [ __ ] senate chambers or
whatever this is going to embolden them
even more this is a symbol for them to
hang on to for
the next four years or whatever or more
where they don't have trump in the white
house
and i truly fear that it's just going to
get downhill
you have a president who's inviting this
kind of radicalization
and is in fact radicalizing people i
know people who
voted for hillary clinton in 2016 and
then voted for donald trump
trump is pushing people further to the
right the country
has definitely shifted further to the
right i don't think that's a surprise
but i'm saying that this raid on the
capital is just
going to make it even worse and if you
thought that trump's
people were angry vengeful while he was
in power
just wait until he's not in office
because if there's one thing i know
about republicans is that they thrive
off of defeat in a way you know it's
it's scary times i think that
the fear is that we become complacent
with joe biden
as president i hope that a biden
presidency
will you know i don't love joe biden i'm
you know voted for bernie sanders in the
primaries i voted for bernie in the
primaries and
i hope that joe biden a joe biden
presidency can at least
that there can be some healing i don't
think joe biden is going to
fix it i feel like you know it's going
to be hopefully more
normal for a little while but i think
it's going to flare up and
that's what's really sad you know
anyways
um that was a bit of a rant i don't mean
to be a [ __ ] debbie downer or
anything
and for my friends on booktube who who
like watching my book reviews of
stormlight archive and stuff
um don't worry there's gonna be more of
that but i just want to be
talking about current events a little
bit more this was on my mind uh
regarding this uh whole situation it's a
[ __ ] horrible situation it's really
sad
i know a lot of people are scared and
upset anyways um
yeah that's pretty much all i have to
say thank you for watching